he has created a bill requiring men to
get vasectomies by age 40.
state representative chris rabb a
philadelphia democrat supports a
solution to law-making men who want to
control policy on women's and girls
bodies require requiring men by six
weeks into age 40 or after child three
to get vasectomies and it's all in the
name of reproductive rights for women
and girls rabb also wrote the
legislation which was in a response to
restrictive abortion bills around the us
i thought it was as important as a man
to speak up about reproductive rights
rabb said according to whp tv
there are bills and laws that regulate
and restrict bodily autonomy for women
and girls but not so much for men while
the legislation is satirical it's
supposed to add conversation on
reproductive rights
in the statement raab said as long as
the state legislature continues to
restrict the reproductive rights of cis
men as cis women trans men and
non-binary people there should be laws
to address the responsibility of men who
impregnate them that's obviously beside
the law of having to look after the
child and pay child support for the
first 18 years of its life
my sincere hope in introducing this
legislation is that my colleagues in the
general assembly consider the
egregiously gendered double standard
when it comes to curtailing reproductive
health care as it applies to women
reproduc republicans reportedly
responded with abortion and vasectomies
not being equal issues and argued the
bill conversation won't get very far
what do you think about that
so
the the main thing that i heard from and
and what i want to talk about is the
satirical aspect of it so like it was
knowingly satirical right when he did it
he
so he himself knows that it's not ever
going to get passed and it's not real so
what i'm wondering is what is the
efficacy of like an extreme
satirical
play like that
to get conversation started
well ultimately right like to to get
people thinking about you know the other
side of it which is
the um
abortion laws that are being passed it's
it's very interesting obviously it's
ridiculous right he even knows it's
ridiculous
um
but that's what i'm i'm wondering is
like how how effective is satire
in bringing about conversation and i
would say it's decently effective right
you have um well we're talking about it
yeah exactly and and
what sort of effect will it have on the
actual lawmakers and
the uh you know the people in power who
can
you know make a difference and and make
changes i don't know if i want the
people that represent me in government
to be wasting time and money
doing [ __ ] like this though that just
yeah
is that the satire no matter how [ __ ]
effective it is it needs to be
unbelievably effective because he's put
a bill in i don't i have no idea it's
waste of time yeah but he's created a
bill and it's actually been put out into
the world
is there not more important things to do
your country's [ __ ]
like the government and the politicians
in your country
are [ __ ]
it's a a guy is basically trolling at
like the elite level professional
trolling yeah yeah yeah i mean i'd
rather you know tax dollars go elsewhere
for sure
for sure than that and that
it's a it's insane um
but you know here we are talking about
it
yeah fair point i also
i don't know i feel like
trying to
further restrict
in response to a restriction
is just a bad
uh it's not a tremendously good way to
try and even the scales right if you
have a problem with a particular law
let's say it's restrictions on voter id
you don't then try and restrict
something else to even the scales you
try to reduce the restriction that
you've got a problem with and the same
thing goes with abortion law like if
you're bothered about the restrictions
on abortions then
you can fight that but trying to create
something that sits on the opposite side
of the fence it makes it too easy if he
genuinely cared i think there would have
been a smarter way to go about this
because it's not it's not the same it's
not equivalent it would it would be the
same as a woman getting her tubes tied
which
right isn't the same as an abortion
yeah they that doesn't match up
for me at all really restricting
someone's ability to reproduce
um and then the other one is
you know the the person has already
reproduced yeah and then you're right
taking a life which is what the
people that are pro-life are arguing
that bit about uh there should be laws
to address the responsibility of men who
impregnate women it's like
what do you mean like there already are
yeah there's um
you have to pay for the child
there's child support yeah for a very
long time already exist anyway yeah
that's
that's what i've been thinking about
this week
yeah that's it's that's incredibly odd
it sounds like it would be a headline to
an onion article
[Laughter]
right
wouldn't it be i mean like
i i honestly when you brought it up i
i've never heard of this but when you
brought it up i thought it was like a uh
like a population control type of play
like like china
yeah thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe makes me very happy
indeed
peace